mais d'abord explications et réactions
autour de ces chiffres record du chômage
avec jérôme rabier c'est une baisse
unique qui non seulement ils fassent la
hausse de l'année 2020 marquée par la
crise du coc vide mais ramène le chômage
à son plus bas niveau depuis 2012 en un
an le nombre de personnes sans activité
inscrits à pôle emploi a chuté de 520000
il y a désormais un peu plus de 3,3
millions de français dans cette
catégorie à des résultats qui
réjouissent le gouvernement sur un an ce
sont 12 6 % de chômeurs en moins c'est
cinq cent mille personnes sans aucune
activité en moins notre taux de chômage
est au plus bas depuis près de 15 ans et
le taux d'emploi est au plus haut depuis
1975 dans notre pays dans le détail ce
sont les jeunes de moins de 25 ans qui
bénéficient le plus de cette baisse avec
un recul de 17,8 pour cent en un an
métropole contre un repli de 8,2 pour
cent pour les plus de 50 ans la
politique du quoi qu'il en coûte avec
notamment la prise en charge par l'état
du chômage partiel semble avoir porté
ses fruits durant cette période reste un
point noir sur lequel il faut accentuer
l'effort pour la cfdt malheureusement
ces chiffres ils cachent aussi des
réalités c'est qu'il ya encore plusieurs
millions de personnes qui sont des
demandeurs d'emploi longue durée et qui
va falloir accompagner vers le retour
vers le retour à l'emploi les chômeurs
de longue durée représentent près de la
moitié des inscrits à pôle emploi est
pour eux la baisse du chômage a été
limitée à 6% certaine
le plein emploi est ce que c'est pour
bientôt et le titre de notre débat je
présente mes invités dominique arlac
bonsoir soir vous êtes vice-président de
porte parole du medef marylise les ondes
en soi secrétaire générale adjointe de
la cfdt anne-sophie alci françois chef
économiste du cabinet de conseil bdo
france et lætitia krupa hitwise
politique bienvenus
à toute une baisse de 5 120 mille
chômeurs en un an la vue dans le sujet
c'est historique première depuis que
cette statistique existe depuis 1996 on
peut peut-être commencer tout simplement
par se réjouir de ces chiffres de
minicar lac je vais d'abord me réjouir
sur un préalable je suis très heureuse
que sur des sujets économiques et
sociaux mais avant tout économique vous
ayez invité quatre femmes je vous
félicite et je nous félicitent midam net
autour de ce débat je sais que c'est
hors de propos un petit peu mais je suis
très content moi je les sujets à venir
je voulais pas le signaler parce que je
pense que ça sera parfait quand on y
pense quand même plus mais bref
saison de me dire bon alors alors oui
c'est donc c'est quand même une très
bonne nouvelle cette baisse c'est
historique du chômage
c'est probablement la principale raison
c'est cette reprise qui est très
dynamique et qui est quelque part a même
effacé ce qu'on avait connu comme crise
ce qui pour nous est le signe est la
démonstration que le chômage on le règle
par la croissance en fait on règle le
problème d'emploi par la croissance et
quand la croissance dépasse les
espérances et bien assez mécaniquement
on a moins de chômage alors il ya une
deuxième bonne nouvelle et une troisième
bonne nouvelle et puis après il ya quand
même quelques nuages et je pense qu'on
partagera à ces nuages autour de ce
plateau la deuxième bonne nouvelle c'est
que les déclarations d'embauché de plus
d'un mois c'est à dire ceux qui
travaillent pas longtemps les contrats
courts ont augmenté enfin ceux qui
travaillent plus longtemps que moi plus
exactement augmenté de 35% donc ça veut
dire qu'on essaye d'aller vers du
travail à une précarisation un peu moins
de précarisation et on essaie d'aller
vers du travail un peu plus durable donc
ça c'est une bonne nouvelle et puis si
l'on en croit les statistiques mais là y
aura peut-être des bas les chômeurs de
catégories b et c finalement la baisse
de ce chômage là est plus forte la
baisse du chômage est plus forte donc on
espère que ce qui était dans l' l'emploi
le chômage durable vont petit à petit en
sortir mais ça nous amène à d'autres
débats qui sont comment en règle le
problème structurel de l'inadéquation
entre le travail et
et on va évidemment l'évoqué marylise
les ans est ce que c'est quand même pas
aussi un rattrapage après une année 2009
1 qui a été difficile pour pas dire oui
alors moi je partage le fait que c'est
une très bonne nouvelle et
j'ai deux 2 mois de sujets de
préoccupation c'est la durabilité de
cette croissance sa solidité je pense
qu'il faut qu'on soit quand même en
demeure prudent il ya quand même une
bonne partie de l'économie qui est
encore sous perfusion avec des aides
publiques dans certains secteurs où on
sait que ça il faut rester prudent pour
être se réjouir définitivement deux sets
de 7 de cette nouvelle baisse du chômage
et puis ça a été évoqué aussi il faut
rester vigilant sur la lan jeu de
d'insertion ou d'emplois durables
c'est-à-dire que les personnes qui
retrouvent un emploi se soit pas pour
quelques semaines mais qu'elle puisse
vraiment s'inscrire dans un parcours et
pouvoir évoluer et puis il reste quand
même plus de 5 millions de chômeurs donc
il ya aussi cette question des chômeurs
de longue durée qui ont été confrontées
à la crise de plein fouet pour lesquels
il faut je pense imaginez ou en tout cas
déployer des dispositifs un peu
différent parce qu'on sait que plus on
est éloigné de l'emploi plus c'est
difficile d'y retrouver anne sophie sans
être trop technique mais c'est vrai que
bon voila moi je peux je préfère me dire
peut-être que tout le monde ne capte pas
tout quand on dit catégories a b c etc
quand on comment on passe de 3 millions
à 5 millions peut-être expliquer en
quelques mots rapidement alors c'est en
fonction de combien d'heures vous avez
travaillé dans le mois donc seul écran
car souvent la catégorie à puisque ce
sont les personnes qui n'ont vraiment
pas du tout du tout travaillé donc c'est
souvent ce chiffre qui est un bon
indicateur quand en effet il ya des
hausses ou des fluctuations donc c'est
vrai que c'est vraiment plus tôt là
dessus qu'il faut regarder mais en effet
les autres catégories ça montre aussi
vous pouvez avoir autant à l'emploi qui
est plus pérenne avec des contrats qui
sont en en effet plus efficient dans le
temps pour revenir sur ce qui a été viré
d'un point de vue économique déjà c'est
de dire que le fameux quoi qu'il en
coûte et efficace on a eu beaucoup de
débats sur l'endettement et bien ses 20
points de dettes qu'on a pris ont quand
même des résultats dont je me sens le
salua sont heureusement donc ça c'est
quand même déjà une très bonne nouvelle
le chômage des moins de 25 ans alors là
aussi c'est eux qui ont en profité le
plus et c'est une bonne nouvelle parce
que sur un an c'est quand même eux qui
ont été les grandes victimes de la crise
il faut le rappeler dont beaucoup de
jeunes cons pas pu rentrer en emploi
parce que passer à deux stages pas deux
dernières études et donc on refait un an
ou qui sont dans une situation délicate
donc ça veut dire que ces jeunes
trouvent un emploi et rentrer et c'est
très important économiquement parce que
en france votre premier emploi détermine
dix ans après votre carrière beaucoup
plus que dans les autres pays de l'osce
est d ailleurs comment c'est à dire que
la filière où le métier dans lequel vous
êtes en france va déterminer votre
carrière sur dix ans alors que par
exemple dans les autres pays de la
cedeao au bout de 5 6 ans vous pouvez
changer de voie ou même d'emploi de
france est beaucoup plus déterminants
votre premier poste même dans votre
métier dans votre spécialisation donc
c'est pour ça que c'est très important
et que c'était vraiment le point
difficile de la crise et de se dire
attention il faut pas avoir une
génération sacrifiée parce que ça aurait
pu l'être et puis aussi le taux d'emploi
on l'a dit des seniors des plus de 55
ans là aussi qu'on en profite et qu'il
faut mettre au regard du nombre de
créations d'entreprises qui s'est envolé
notamment les plus petites entreprises
qui veut dire aussi que des personnes
qui pourraient être éloignés de l'emploi
en en profiter pour créer leur activité
et devenir auto entrepreneur ou
indépendants et ça c'est vraiment une
tendance qui va s'accélérer donc on voit
qu'on a plusieurs phénomènes pas
seulement une reprise rattrapage mais
vraiment des mutations général sur
marché de l'emploi alors on parlera ici
évidemment et quantifiables l'impact
politique de de ces mots de plein emploi
dont on va parler souvent dans ce débat
mais c'est évidemment un travail
collectif de dominique car là qu est ce
que vous diriez je vais vous poser la
même question après maryse les que le
dialogue social est plus efficace depuis
quelques années et que vous a donné des
outils pour être plus efficace en tout
cas on l'a démontré pendant la crise qu
vide parce que s'il ya une entité qui a
été épargné dans cette crise est plutôt
les entreprises parce que les
entreprises ont dialogué hauteur
d'entreprise pour faire assurer la
continuité du travail et la protection
visuelle galets qui bat les partenaires
sociaux mais entreprise par entreprise
entreprise par entreprise pour assurer
la continuité du travail l'organisation
du travail et j'ai pas noté pendant les
deux ans de crise qui ait eu des
conflits majeurs et qu'on est pointé du
doigt les entreprises où les salariés
d'ailleurs sur le fait que ça ne
tournait pas dans les entreprises moi
j'aurais rebondir quand même sur un
point que vous avez soulevés tout à
l'heure qui est le point d'interrogation
qu'on peut partager c'est la durabilité
de cette reprise parce que c'est vrai
qu'à hauteur d'une pme peut-être qu il
ya des grandes entreprises qui ont plus
de visibilité ma hauteur de pme comme ya
eu effectivement ce quoi qu'il en coûte
qui a permis de doper les entreprises
donc elle j'en suis engagé il ya eu cet
effet de survie en quelque sorte des
subventions soit le prêt garanti par
l'état mais
voilà il ya eu ça maintenant les vraies
conditions de l'économie c'est quand
même pas d'avoir une économie sous
perfusion de l'état donc du coup la
question qu'on peut se poser c'est la
durabilité de tout ça donc pour que ça
soit durable cet emploi et ce chômage
qui se réduit il faut un maintien de la
croissance mais la vraie croissance
économique d'une part et 2 une
adéquation entre l'emploi et les
compétences parce que sinon on aura
toujours ce chômage structurel qui fait
qu'il y aura des youyous parce que si la
croissance elle repart à la baisse mais
c'est mal une adéquation entre l'emploi
et des compétences ça veut dire
qu'aujourd'hui en fait vous avez des
secteurs qui mute toutes les
transformations que la société demande
et que les entreprises entreprennent
transformation numérique
environnementales écologiques
énergétiques
nécessite des nouveaux métiers et
mécaniquement dans tous les secteurs il
ya des métiers qui sont en tension il ya
des métiers qui sont déclin il ya des
messieurs qui sont émergents années
messier qui sont en développement ceux
qui sont en émergence et en
développement on n'a pas à la tout de
suite ni les jeunes pour pourvoir les
postes ni les anciens pour être adapté à
ses nouvelles compétences dont il ya de
la tension sur des compétences et dallas
et les écoles sont pas adaptés aux
mutations base encore la société la
société nous voulons les consommateurs
on est encore en attente de nouvelles
sociaux solutions de mobilité de santé
de téléphonie etc on veut tout de suite
l'innovation on veut tout de suite les
produits sauf que les temps de cycle
d'innovation et de formation compétences
c'est plus long que la volonté d'avoir
tout de suite des choses transformer
maryse léon je repose la question sur
dialogue social ma vision
[Musique]
qui a été dit est tout à fait juste il
ya eu du dialogue intense dans les
entreprises parce que les salariés qui
qui aiment leur travail pour une très
très grande majorité d'entre eux pendant
la crise ils ont su répondre présent et
ils ont ils ont maintenu l'activité ils
ont tenu tenu l'activité de leur
entreprise et et ils ont été extrêmement
ils ont vraiment joué la carte de ils se
sont engagés investit donc être changée
par d'en interrompre un peu aussi sur le
leurs patrons qui eux aussi se battait
pour que pour que la tuberie style très
particulier dans le mode crash dans une
période de crise et de gestion de crise
avait chez d'une entreprise forcément
qu' il ya des moins d'actualité c'est
bien moins de conflits qualité il ya un
peu plus de proximité aussi il ya
peut-être aussi est ce qu'il faudrait
préserver c'est un peu plus aussi de
transparence de la part des employeurs
pour expliquer la situation
pointé les risques et puis faire en
sorte que tout le monde voilà tout le
monde joue le jeu et s'engage là où
le dialogue a été intense notamment à
l'échelle des entreprises les branches
ont aussi joué le jeu on parle de
l'activité partielle il ya l'activité
partielle longue durée qui a été proposé
par les organisations syndicales et
patronales qui doit faire l'objet de
négociations
parce que ça veut dire qu'il ya des
concessions qui peuvent être faites par
par les salariés en matière de
modulation d'horaire en matière de
salaires
en contrepartie de maintien de l'emploi
c'est ça qui est aussi important c'est
cdu c'est du donnant-donnant ou du
gagnant gagnant mais est il ya eu pas
mal de négociations il ya des accords
qui ont été négociées à l'échelle des
branches et je pense que ça c'est une
une innovation qui a pu être possible
grâce au dialogue social qui mérite
d'être qui mérite d'être souligné et
puis de voir comment on peut faire
perdurer ces systèmes il ya un exemple
qui illustre le propos de la rénovation
du dialogue social et la force du
dialogue social c'est là et ni l'accord
national interprofessionnel a été signée
fin 2021 l'année dernière concernant le
télétravail fait tous les partenaires
sociaux se sont mis d'accord et en fait
c'est pas un accord qui a créé une
nouvelle norme de nouvelles obligations
de nouveaux droits c'est un accord dont
l'intitulé était comment réussir la mise
en place du télétravail en entreprise
donc on est d'offrir une approche qui
n'est pas conflictuel qui est en fait
comment on s'y prend pour réussir la
mise en place du télétravail c'est pas
la même approche que c'est quoi les
contreparties là c'était vraiment
comment on réussit et comment se met
d'accord pour mettre en place ces
travail pardon c'est pérenne ou pas
c'est la question qu'on se pose puisque
comme ces nouvelles pratiques est ce que
on va continuer
mais ça dépend beaucoup des secteurs
donc c'est vrai que les secteurs qui
sont plus dématérialisé et souvent les
cadres catégories intellectuelles
supérieures sont un peu les grands
gagnants donc c'est vrai que ça augmente
les gains de productivité en évaluation
de 15 à 20 % puisque en effet mené
depuis les temps de transport vous avez
beaucoup moins de pauses l'allée des
plages horaires en fait travailler plus
chez vous
john cacioppo donc faudrait gains de
productivité de l'autre côté le fait de
pouvoir entre des bureaux qui peuvent
être assez onéreux en termes de coûts
c'est vrai que pour les entreprises
c'est assez intéressant ce sommet
immobilier à montceau celle de
l'immobilier d'entreprise
jospeh entreprises au niveau des
salariés c'est vrai que les différents
sondages montraient que les personnes
voulaient deux trois jours de
télétravail donc il ya vraiment eu
maintenant une accoutumance et beaucoup
moins subi donc là aussi est vraiment
l'idée de dire et ça correspond par
rapport à ce qu'on voit sur les
créations d'entreprises plus d'autonomie
et de plus d'indépendants donc ça en
effet c'est plutôt positif après
attention ça dépend beaucoup des
secteurs ça dépend beaucoup quel est
votre emploi et là aussi même pour qu'on
parlait des compétences et des emplois
il va y avoir beaucoup d'inégalités qui
vont pouvoir se créer et qui vont être
beaucoup plus difficile à déceler si une
personne décroche ou en tout cas peut
avoir des difficultés donc ça va être ça
qui va être beaucoup plus difficile
les personnes assez autonome
indépendante vont plutôt être les
gagnantes en plus on voit que les jeunes
générations c'est très apprécié parce
que ça veut dire plus de responsabilités
plus initiative - de l'hiérarchie plus
de capacité le monde qui est fait à
l'embauché qu'en ce moment on plaisait
dans des secteurs où ou sous ces tests
sont ceux qui cherchent un emploi qui
ont finalement la position forte combien
jours de télétravail exactement plus de
sens dans l'aspect révolution écologique
en termes de transport on a quand même
des millions de gens qui chaque jour
vont même endroit ça fait aussi du sens
on parle en termes de prix de carburants
donc on voit que c'est vraiment en effet
l'avenir après attention c'est vraiment
différencier par secteur mais
globalement sacré plus de gains de
productivité
alors on va employer ces mots plein
emploi et c'est de leur donner du sens
du sens économique du sens politique
laëtitia le plein emploi est ce que
c'est possible en france on va répondre
à cette question c'est d'abord un une
arme politique pour l'exécutif on peut
dire ça oui une arme naissante c'est
assez récent cet élément de langage
parce que on va le voir et l'écouter de
plus en plus dans la bouche de l'équipe
d' emmanuel macron quand il se décidera
enfin entrer en campagne en tout cas
l'un de ses plus fidèles lieutenants
bruno le maire commence à préparer le
terrain il était chez france info dans
la matinale et c'est vrai qu'à la toute
fin d'émission il a commencé à
émettre cette hypothèse de plein emploi
comme une stratégie d'entrée en campagne
pour le candidat macron jour oppose de
l'écouté je pense véritablement que les
meilleures années de la france sont
devant tel que nous avons aujourd'hui la
possibilité d'atteindre le plein emploi
pour la première fois depuis un demi
siècle et moi quand on me dit pour
arrachage dit oui je fais attention je
protège je prends les décisions sur
l'énergie mais la vraie réponse de long
terme c'est le plein emploi le plein
emploi qualifié le plein emploi bien
payé et nous sommes grâce au présent la
public sur cette voie pourquoi ce sera
une thématique centrale thomas là on a
vraiment en fait une illustration
concrète et direct déjà il répond à la
question actuelle du pouvoir d'achat
mais il la dépasse c'est à dire qu'elle
dit oui bien sûr je réponds pouvoir
d'achat puisque le plein emploi répond
d'une façon directe et indirecte au
pouvoir d'achat mais il la dépasse et ce
sera effectivement la façon dont
emmanuel macron pas se présenter dans
cette campagne c'est à dire que oui on
traite bien sur les questions urgentes
et immédiates mais on a un coup d'avancé
sur les autres loin bien sûr et pourquoi
ce sera aussi un très bon sujet de
campagne porter parce que d'une barbe à
ça lui permet de faire un bilan positif
de son quinquennat quand même et d'autre
part de placer le travail au centre
d'une campagne dans le travail concerne
tout le monde le travail c'est un pilier
de la société et surtout ça fixe un
objectif parce que la question à
laquelle doit répondre emmanuel macron
enfin qu'on va tous se poser si oui ou
non on va voter pour untel ou untel en
tout cas le concernant c'est pourquoi
emmanuel macron 50 plus à l'elysée
pourquoi pour faire quoi et bien bruno
le maire a répondu les belles années de
la france sont devant elle vous voyez
donc on commence à se dessiner un peu la
toile de fond de la campagne des manuels
macro et on va l'entendre comme je vous
le disais de plus en plus elisabeth
bande a repris ce matin ce mot dans sa
bouche écoutez la avec cette évolution
très positive un conte connaît ces
derniers mois je pense que ça nous donne
une fectivement le chemin on va
continuer pour effectivement arrivé au
plein emploi c'est ce qu'on peut
souhaiter pour nous un pays d'avoir un
maximum de français qui est un travail
voilà vous avez vu alors on a bien
compris comment était balisé le chemin
de la pré campagne d' emmanuel macron
mais il y a peut-être un petit sujet la
traiter côté exécutif d'ailleurs ils
sont en train de plancher dessus ensuite
elisabeth bornes quand on la questionne
sur d'accord mais comment définissez
vous le plein emploi elle dit oui se
situe autour de 5 6 % de taux de chômage
bon je suis sûr qu autour de cette table
personne n'est d'accord ils savent très
bien que ça va faire l'objet d'une
querelle entre spécialistes et donc là
ils sont en train de plancher sur
l'acceptation la plus acceptable la
définition la plus accessible
pour le plein emploi pour que la
majorité adhère à cette idée du paint
enfants moi dans mes souvenirs c'était
4%
c'est pour ça que par rapport à ce que
ce que vous avez dit alors c'est vrai
qu'en france on a été habitué aux 8% là
on essaie on espère 7,5 cette année
peut-être 7% après en 2023 et d'arrivée
peut-être si vraiment tout va bien à 6
donc on est encore deux trois points
d'écart par rapport à par exemple ce
qu'on va en allemagne ou aux états unis
même si c'est pas comparable par rapport
à la structuration du marché du travail
l'allemagne etats unis son tour de 4,5 à
exactement moins de 4 pour les états
unis un petit qu'ils ont vraiment des
aidants pénurie en plus ils ont de
l'inflation donc sans vraiment une
boucle pénurie salaires qui se met en
place l'allemagne veut ils ont une autre
difficulté c'est qu'ils perdent
énormément chaque année de travailleurs
sur le marché de l'emploi ça reste la
première puissance industrielle
française dont qu'ils ont le
vieillissement de la peau plus douce
vieillissement de la population donc où
ils font de l'immigration de travail
massive ou en tout cas ils essaient
d'être attractif et d'attirer notamment
des citoyens extra-européens entreprises
ont des besoins de main d'oeuvre qui
seront absolument colossaux ça reste la
première puissance industrielle en
europe donc ils sont vraiment sur cette
tendance donc nous on a quand même ses
deux trois points mais qui reste c'est
vrai que les bonnes nouvelles c'est on
l'a dit au niveau des jeunes anglais qui
en profite et on voit que si on fait cet
effort de formation on peut avoir une
baisse qui sont importantes mais là
aussi attention par rapport aux autres
pays européens les jeunes qui décrochent
sont vraiment sans qualification et
c'est cela qu'on a beaucoup plus de mal
à récupérer donc là il aura vraiment un
vrai travail d'investissement pour
essayer de récupérer vraiment les
décrocheurs au niveau des plus de 55 ans
là aussi on voit qu'il ya une
corrélation avec l'âge de départ à la
retraite étant dès qu'on a un âge qui
est à 62 donc plus faible que ce que
l'on peut voir dans les autres pays
européens on voit que quand vous le
décalé et vous l'augmenter et bien en
général le taux de départ en retraite ou
préretraite a tendance à augmenter aussi
donc c'est pour ça qu'on peut aussi
jouer sur le taux d'emploi des seniors
donc ça ça va vraiment des éléments
importants pourraient peut-être à 6%
mais peut-être pas quand même opep pour
home edition envahie et de l'emploi 10 5
6% voilà
alors se mettre d'accord sur
effectivement la définition du du plein
emploi les meilleures années de la
france sont devant elle je reprend la
formule de bruno le maire maryse leone
si on voit donner un satisfecit à ce
gouvernement est ce que c'est sur
l'apprentissage par exemple oui j'ai
fait ressortir une mesure alors c'est
vrai que les chiffres l'apprentissage
sont sont très positifs
ça fait partie des choses qui ont été un
investissement particulier qui a été qui
a été mis sur 7 sur ces dispositifs et
notamment pour répondre à la question de
l'insertion l'insertion des jeunes et
l'insertion durable puisque si on sait
que c'est un tremplin ou en tout cas un
levier pour pouvoir accéder à accéder à
l'emploi
la petite nuance qu'on pourrait apporter
ses c'est penser des dispositifs qui
s'adresse à ceux qui en ont plus besoin
et on voit dans les chiffres de
l'apprentissage que le développement se
fait beaucoup pour des personnes qui ont
des qui préparent des diplômes
supérieurs il ya une très forte
augmentation de ses entrées en
apprentissage et chez chez ces niveaux
pour ses niveaux de qualification nous
notre souci c'est fait gros derrière la
question du plein emploi c'est que
chacun trouve sa place le chacun trouve
un emploi que ce soit 4 5 6%
aujourd'hui on est à plus de 5 millions
c'est 5 millions de personnes qui ne
peuvent pas qu'ils n'ont pas accès aux
cures insuffisamment action à l'emploi
et puis
l'une des promesses qui est faite ou en
tout cas nous l'espoir que l'on a que
dans la campagne on parle enfin des
questions économiques et sociales
lorsque c'est important qu'il y ait
aussi des éléments de justice sociale
c'est qu'on puisse vivre dignement de
son travail et aujourd'hui on a encore
se traduit comment y aller on était dans
le province et vivre pouvoir vivre de
son travail sans avoir forcément recours
à la prime d'activité sans avoir besoin
donc ans à l'heure à 1,2 me un salaire
décent et c'est un peu tout l'enjeu du
moment où c'était
il ya quelques endroits alors c'est pas
généraliser mais en vo à nous pour la
cfdt que c'est un sujet qui cristallise
beaucoup le mécontentement la grogne
c'est la question la question des
salaires alors je vais revenir au
salaire et je vous poserai la question
tout à l'heure on prendra vraiment le
temps de parler salaire et puis chômage
les inégalités parce qu'on peut voir
baisser le chômage mais pas forcément
les inégalités c'est une vraie question
mais sur l'apprentissage ou mika relax
c'est intéressant ce que vous avez dit
parce que je pense que dans l'image dans
l'image collective dans l'inconscient
collectif de l'apprentissage on
n'imagine pas forcément que ce sont les
laits mieux diplômés qui en bénéficient
aujourd'hui vous voyez ce que je veux
dire est-ce que l'apprentissage est
vraiment en train de changer en france
et de se généraliser
nous on a présenté lundi notre
plateforme pour les présidentielles pour
proposer justement de rentrer dans le
débat économique et non pas dans un
débat autres qui nous concerne est un
petit peu moins et donc nous on voudrait
vraiment que le monde économique se
rapproche du monde de lampes de
l'entreprise et le monde économique se
rapproche du système de formation
justement réduire cet écart qu'il peut y
avoir entre formation et besoins en
métiers et donc nous ce qu'on voudrait
c'est viser les 2 million d'alternants
donc dans l'alternance vous avez les
apprentis 2 million d'alternants parce
qu'on sait très bien que tout à l'heure
vous disiez le premier emploi est
déterminant pour les 10 années qui
suivent l'alternance est déterminante
pour l'entrée dans l'emploi aussi
mal à moitié je crois de 7 700 voilà on
a à peine un million mais donc là nous
on devrait doubler on voudrait 2 million
d'alternants mais concerne aussi les
emplois moins qualifiés tous les emplois
parce que justement nous dans notre
plateforme faire réussir la france c'est
la plateforme du medef que nous avons
sortir cette semaine en fait ce que l'on
veut c'est en priorité mieux former la
jeunesse est accordée le plus
d'attention à cette jeunesse qui est en
difficulté parce qu'on sait très bien
qu'après socialement c'est ce qui va
faire peser or je suis assez d'accord
les meilleures années sont devant nous
et toutes les transformations qu'il faut
assumer et quels seront les entreprises
je dis pas qu'on va partir pour les
trente glorieuses dans le monde
glorieuse move loire et que je pense que
ça percute au niveau politique
voilà c'est un fantasme mais je pense
que pour faire réussir la france il va
falloir justement au plus tôt
sensibiliser le monde de l'éducation à
cette insertion des jeunes dans les
besoins de l'économie tels qu'ils sont
aujourd'hui et demain en fait et donc
l'alternance pour ça c'est un très bon
moyen moi je n'ai pas les statistiques
en tête sur le taux de transformation
qu'on a entre en alternant qui passe
deux ans dans une entreprise quelle que
soit son niveau 1 que l'alternance il
soit dans un métier de mécanicien ou
qu'ils soient en 5e année business
school une école de commerce on lui
propose quelque chose l'entreprise lui
propose quelque chose en étant jetés
fort mais tu es déjà professionnaliser
donc je te garde on a été en retard
pendant des décennies
alors se comparer beaucoup à l'allemagne
sur cela qui est vraiment le pays de
l'alternance alors aussi pourquoi
l'allemagne a vraiment été totalement
détruit après la seconde guerre mondiale
et donc la reconstruction du pays s'est
fait par les lander donc au mans par les
régions et donc l'idée c'était vraiment
que les régions forment la jeunesse pour
vraiment réindustraliser et reconstruire
tout ce qu'ils avaient été détruites
donc c'est vrai que l'alternance a été
vraiment un moyen de reconstruire le
pays en france pas du tout hein le but
ça tu es vraiment de développer
l'université et on va dire
l'enseignement plus généraliste est donc
une fois qu'on avait développé cet
enseignement est bien en effet on
considérer quand on avait des citoyens
qui pouvaient aller un peu dans tous les
secteurs confondus et donc la formation
fait ans l'entreprise est bien
permettait de changer de s'adapter donc
ces deux visions différentes qui
explique aussi pourquoi l'alternance
était moins utilisés en france comme
vous l'avait dit en effet les besoins
sont différents et à l'université vous
pouvez avoir dans certaines filières des
taux d'échec ou de chômage qui sont
importants avec des jeunes qui chantent
de filières régulièrement on savait que
l'alternance surtout quand vous êtes
formé dans l'entreprise ou permet
souvent d'avoir un cdi ce qui n'est pas
le cas dans d'autres formations et puis
des rémunérations parce que c'est vrai
que ça a été aussi beaucoup fait dans
l'industrie des rémunérations qui était
moins faible donc c'est vrai que c'est
très attractif et au moment où on a des
transitions notamment numérique est
aussi dans l'industrie notamment par
exemple la robotique ou d'ekobo etc ça
attire aussi beaucoup plus les jeunes
parce que vous avez besoin d'un diplôme
de mécanicien en tout cas de bac + 3
donc vous avez beaucoup plus d'eux tech
dans différentes formations donc c'est
vrai que toutes ces mutations expliqua
beaucoup plus d'attractivité positif et
j'ouvre le chapitre salaire quand même
et inégalités parce que ça me semble
important on a écouté jean luc mélenchon
tout de suite puisque c'est aussi
l'actualité du jour il y avait cette
journée d'action à l'appel de nombreux
syndicats pas la cfdt d'ailleurs ces
lignes je ne me trompe pourquoi pas
d'appel national parce qu'on a fait le
choix des mobilisations sectorielles
d'accord bon c'est clair jean luc
mélenchon il faisait partie des
politiques qui ont décidé de manifester
aujourd'hui on l'écouterait clamer une
hausse des salaires avec nous ils auront
envie pas parce qu'on est pile au seuil
de pauvreté et c'est pas possible de le
faire par conséquent il ya besoin de
venir à l'aide de tout le monde moi là
quand je vous parle du smig à 1400 euros
ça me semblait que vous me posiez cette
question parce que c'est juste pour dire
que ce fait 400 euros net seulement de
plus que le seuil de pauvreté pour
quelqu'un qui travaille souvent dans des
conditions que beaucoup n'accepterai pas
c'est pas une faveur que nous pouvons
réclamer au nom de la société c'est
vraiment quelque chose qui est
indispensable à sa respiration de
socialiser les os qu'on sait peut-être
que vous avez pas la réponse à ces pas
une colle sur les 520 mille emplois qui
ont été créés l'an dernier il ya
beaucoup de bas salaires c'est ce qu'on
a ce qu'on connaît la ventilation la
ventilation je les ai pas en tête
c'est mais toujours est il que le débat
sur les salaires ne peut pas se résumer
au débat sur le smic et l'augmentation
du smic je pense que c'est beaucoup plus
complexe que ça et notamment parce que
le smic n'est pas un outil de lutte
contre la pauvreté le smic est un
salaire d'entrée sur le marché du
travail et que l'enjeu qu'on garde etc
c'est une responsabilité des
organisations syndicales et patronales
de faire en sorte que à l'échelle d'une
branche professionnelle par exemple et
vous n'ayez pas comme c'est le cas dans
pas mal de branches encore aujourd'hui
10 coefficient qui sont censés
correspondre à des compétences
différentes où les personnes seraient ce
sont au smic et peuvent passer leur vie
au smic c'est ça c'est là-dessus qu'il
faut pouvoir travailler donc le travail
il a déjà commencé ça fait l'objet d'une
négociation alors on a alors du coup
c'est pas l'état qui décide c'est aussi
la responsabilité et la capacité qu'on a
avancé avec les organisations syndicales
et patronales et new skies ce qui fait
l'objet de nos mobilisations
sectorielles c'est qu'il ya des
négociations de branche qui n'avance pas
d'autres qui se sont conclus récemment
je pense notamment au hcr où il ya eu 16
% d'augmentation l'ours et hôtellerie
cafés restauration excusez moi je n'y
mets ou en parallèle de ces difficultés
de vivre dignement de son travail
d'avoir des horaires compatibles avec
des horaires de travail compatible avec
sa vie personnelle
c'est un des secteurs qui a connu le
plus de départs pendant la crise
sanitaire puisque les salariés se sont
questionnés sur leurs conditions de
travail l'organisation de leur travail
et ont préféré aller dans d'autres
métiers comme la logistique parce que
quitte à être payés au smic ils se sont
ils ont préféré avoir leur sort et leur
week end donc c'est une responsabilité
des branches on à nous mobiliser
inciter fortement à ce qu'il puisse y
avoir des niveaux et on a réussi à
obtenir un accord avec +16 % d
augmentation de salaire en moyenne et
donc voilà là on fait des donc syndicale
ça veut dire dans une carla que c'est
possible là en l'occurrence le les
patrons de ce secteur de l'hôtellerie
cafés restauration il n'avait pas le
choix puisqu'il n'arrivait plus à
recruter donc ça veut dire que la marge
de manoeuvre elle existait ou est ce que
je veux dire en fait la marge de
manoeuvre existe parce qu'il y ait le
rebond il ya la reprise donc dès lors
vous avez une reprise c'est ce qui
explique d'une part la baisse du chômage
d'autres var la possibilité d'augmenter
le salaire quand vous avez les moyens de
créer de l'emploi et d'augmenter les
salaires vous le faites pour pouvoir
pérenniser votre entreprise le point sur
lequel nous et je vous interromps parce
que je me mets dans la tête de certains
qui nourrit un petit 10 oui mais ok mais
souvent les patrons ils vont pas et ils
vont pas augmenter parce qu'ils sont pas
forcés de le faire quand il ya une
situation critique que celle qu'ont vécu
les patrons de la restauration de la
houle a enlevé café bon bah ils ont bien
augmenté de 16% envoyé en fait c'est
malheureusement une vieille loi de
l'offre et la demande aujourd'hui c'est
clairement la demande d'emploi qui fait
l'offre d'emploi c'est-à-dire en gros le
salarié à un pouvoir de négociation
largement supérieur à ce qu'on a pu
avoir par ce que il ya pénurie d'emplois
il ya pénurie et des places qui sont non
pourvus donc effectivement ça
rééquilibre quelque part le dialogue
social à hauteur c'est la dea sur le sur
le point du salaire maintenant la hausse
généralisée tous secteurs confondus
c'est révolu c'est révolu parce qu'on a
bien vu pendant la crise précisément que
toutes les entreprises ne sont pas logés
à la même enseigne que toutes les
entreprises ne subissent pas les crises
de la même manière et donc qu'on soit
petites entreprises ou grandes
entreprises c'est déjà pas la même chose
mais surtout d'un secteur à l'autre
c'est difficile de tirer une loi de
comportement disant monbalen voilà il va
falloir mettre les salaires puissent 10%
par tout ça ça n'est plus possible de
partir sur en guerre j'irai pour
augmenter globalement et de manière
généralisée les salaires parce qu'encore
une fois certains secteurs ne peuvent
pas suivre en revanche la bonne nouvelle
je dirais la bonne nouvelle c'est que
cette année les négociations sont en
cours dans les entreprises et dans les
branches vous avez rappelé le secteur de
l'hôtellerie café restaurant à +16 % et
il n'y aura pas que ces éléments là il
va y avoir aussi des éléments de travail
d'organisation du travail où c'est la
branche par exemple de la propreté qui a
pris les devants la branche de la
propreté c'est le ménage industriels et
professionnels dans les soins dans les
locaux tertiaires ou dans les locaux
secondaire on a dans la mesure du
possible organiser le travail pendant
les heures de travail de là où on fait
le ménage plutôt que de travailler très
tôt le matin ou très tard le soir et ça
c'est une vraie attente des salariés
mais pourquoi finalement dans les trains
c'est pareil pourquoi finalement on ne
travaillerait pas pendant que les gens
sont aussi au travail et ça c'est pour
le coup la branche et la fédération de
la propreté des employeurs de la
propreté qui l'ont proposé qui ont
devancé l'appel pour résoudre ce
problème de on ne trouve pas de monde
donc il faut être plus attractif
simplement d'ailleurs sur ce thème et
sur ce secteur où vous pouvez voir le
film ouistreham du livre enquête de
florence aubenas qui est vraiment
passionnant sur cette question des
salaires de la réduction des inégalités
parce que c'est vrai que si on voit le
chômage baisser mais les inégalités
pour certains augmentent et en tout cas
pour les plus pauvres par rapport aux
plus riches si si si je pense ce
comparatif là socialement c'est
difficile à accepter ça va vraiment être
ça l'enjeu notamment dans l'est dans les
transitions alors c'est vrai que là par
mois à ce que vous disiez l'offre et la
demande enfin c'est ça va resté
l'économie est sur l'offre et la demande
etc en effet quand vous avez moins de
main d'oeuvre bien forcément vous avez
des augmentations de salaire si on le
voit bien aux etats unis c'est quelque
chose de mécanique on peut pas dire
qu'avec des fois on entend va augmenter
de tant de temps non c'est par secteur
et ça dépend et c'est en fonction de
voilà de l'offre et de la demande ce qui
va jouer aussi beaucoup c'est vraiment
le développement des indépendants et là
on le voit notamment vous parler des
inégalités dans les salaires vous allez
en avoir une inégalité importante par
rapport à ce qu'on disait le choc
technologique donc vous allez avoir les
secteurs des services de l'état et
l'économie numérique a fait par rapport
à l'industrie et par rapport à la
numérisation et tout ce qui est donné
comme on l'a paraît tout à l'heure avec
le télétravail et là ça va être très
important parce qu'on le voit déjà les
les ingénieurs en fin d'école ou qui
peuvent être embauchés dans tout ce qui
est d'atteindre des salaires bien plus
élevé quand même ce que l'on pouvait
avoir à vent et par contre dans les
séries vous avez vous pouvez avoir une
paupérisation qui existent et qui peut
augmenter avec justement les transitions
numérique écologique donc ça ce sera un
vrai sujet comment faire d'avoir en
effet un salaire minimum on peut vivre
et des conditions attractives et c'est
pour ça que beaucoup on l'a vu pendant
la crise qu bing ont fait des formations
pour au lieu de se dire bien voilà je
vais aller faire en effet du show du
ménage dans une entreprise ou être
serveur dans un restaurant et bien je
vais me mettre en indépendant jeu comme
ça je maîtrise mon temps de travail je
peux avoir plus de rémunération et on le
voit par exemple aux états unis dans la
plomberie à tous les sérieuses avec eux
des plateformes et vous prenez quelqu'un
pendant une heure d'utilisation de
l'économie ticket dénoncé aussi
fortement parce qu'il n'y a pas de
protection sociale et là vous allez
avoir la main le faisaient leurs achats
que
vous allez avoir la question de la
protection sociale d'où justement et les
choix que rumeurs ont commencé sur ce
plan et même où que ce soit au royaume
uni aux états unis vous avez des procès
qui ont été gagnés de dire on veut être
indépendant on veut gagner plus mais en
même temps on veut une protection
sociale merci beaucoup merci à tous